if we look at the Eagles as it hurts or  the team I think it's a little bit of  both man I think  it's system and team they got a great  offensive line which helps hurts hurts  has AJ Brown and Devonta Smith they got  a good running game I mean all right bro  like the eagle cowboy coming up ain't it  yeah it's coming up I'm not trying to  make no enemies I I just like I just  love the game so much and I understand  it so much that like like when things  are off I just can't like hold it in  like I almost got to say something like  his stats and what he's been doing with  the numbers that he's putting up is MVP  worthy just like with Patrick moans  doing but that passed with Patrick  Mahomes was nuts was insane bro but  that's what he does my homes is an MVP